des tunisiens entre espoir et
incertitudes au lendemain de la
nomination du nouveau gouvernement
quelle est l'atmosphère à tunis le point
avec notre correspondant basse et au
chili
ils auront attendu plus de deux mois
pour enfin voir les premiers traits de
cette nouvelle à tunisie promise par le
chef de l'état kaïs saïd depuis son coup
de force du 25 juillet dernier hier
après des mois d'incertitudes les
tunisiens ont découvert en direct à la
télévision leur nouveau gouvernement 25
ministres dont neuf femmes conduite par
najlae bouden première femme chef de
gouvernement du monde arabe pour de
nombreux tunisiens ce nouveau chapitre
de leur histoire apparaît comme un
nouvel espoir une occasion de redresser
le pays plongé dans une crise économique
et sociale que les précédents
gouvernements n'ont fait qu'aggraver ces
dix dernières années écoutez nous avons
tunisie beaucoup de femmes très
compétente je suis très optimiste car sa
mission est bien déterminée est clair
c'est ce que nous demandons qu'ils
aillent à l'essentiel nous n'avons pas
besoin du discours politique nous avons
besoin d'une relance de l'économie de
nouveaux partenaires étrangers
l'acquisition de nouveaux marchés nous
voulons que les jeunes quand ils se
lèvent le matin trouve un travail et des
opportunités pour la tunisie c'est une
nouveauté quoi ccc un buzz comme ça ça
va se faire mais ça veut pas dire que
avec une certitude qu'elle va réussir
qu'elle n'avait pas réussir donc on doit
lui donner sa chance elle va développer
ses avis et ses plans d'action et serra
et on l'espère bien bien sûr que ça va
marcher
ce qu'elle réussisse ou pas ça je
rejouerai qu aucune idée mais c'est pas
qu'une femme que ça va réussir ou bien
c'est juste des les pensées de chacun
d'eux que ce soit une femme ou un homme
ça va pas changer la réalité sauf si
elle va intervenir avec des actions de
de son point de vue comme est enfin
peut-être qu'elles doivent développer
des choses que un homme pourrait pas
voir ou alors à un de trop propositions
supplémentaires positive négative dont
on va voir
moi j'ai 60 ans et je suis retraité donc
je n'ai plus grand chose à attendre mais
je souhaite quand même que mon pays
aille mieux il faut que le pays se
remette à travailler que les jeunes
puissent travailler c'est pour ça qu'on
espère un renouveau de la part de ce
gouvernement qu'il nettoie enfin le pays
et relance l'économie nationale que les
conditions de vie s'améliorent pour
qu'enfin le pauvre puisse respirer c'est
tout ce qu'on attend du nouveau
gouvernement
je suis très heureuse et pour être
honnête l'idée que ce soit une femme à
la tête du gouvernement cela me plaît
beaucoup c'est une première en tunisie
et dans le monde arabe la femme a son
mot à dire et elle a des choses à
proposer elle est capable de grandes
choses et déjà plus de la moitié des
femmes en tunisie dirigent leurs foyers
je suis sûr que cette femme au pouvoir
peut réussir
le pays attendait un tel événement les
grâces à dieu on nier le président avait
besoin de temps pour trouver ses repères
et travailler pour le bien du pays car
malheureusement en tunisie nous n'avions
pas beaucoup de personnes de confiance
nous aimons notre tunisie nous lâche
hérisson mais nous n'avions pas beaucoup
de politiciens de confiance et
aujourd'hui grâce à l'aide de dieu
espérons que cela marque un nouveau
départ et qu'il s'occupe enfin de
l'agriculture fragilisé et du quotidien
des citoyens des pauvres et des affamés
ces nouveaux ministres n'ont pas besoin
de garde rapprochée et des mercedes de
luxe dernier cri
malgré l'optimisme et la prudence de
beaucoup de tunisiens face à cette
nouvelle équipe gouvernementale ou des
femmes ont été nommées à des postes clés
comme la justice ou encore les finances
le pays demeure plongée dans une crise
économique et les caisses de l'état est
en vider la croissance stagnante à 3%
selon l'institut national des
statistiques
najlae bouden et son équipe jouiront de
prérogatives considérablement réduite
pour relancer un exécutif à l'arrêt
depuis le 25 juillet dernier malgré la
nomination d'une nouvelle chef du
gouvernement le président de la
république demeure le réel détenteur du
pouvoir exécutif
notamment en présidant le conseil des
ministres grâce aux mesures
exceptionnelles qu'il a décrété le mois
dernier chez la chef du gouvernement a
annoncé que son équipe devra au mieux
pour restaurer la confiance des
tunisiens dans l'état et améliorer leurs
conditions de vie avec un programme où
la lutte contre la corruption sera
l'objectif prioritaire